CBS News legal analyst Ricky Clement is
here to sort this all out there's a lot
to sort out Ricky Clemens so where do we
begin first the president's denied that
he knew anything about a payment now
rudy guiliani according to some White
House staffers stunned everybody by
making this admission and then saying
well he might have he paid it but the
president didn't really know what it was
for who pays one hundred and thirty
thousand dollars and doesn't know what
it's for
well it goes along with rudy giuliani's
other comments that these people are
busy people yes so we have to do these
things all the time what's our strategy
be I just want to add and good then go
to their strategy okay not in any law
firm I have ever worked so let's look at
what their legal strategy was or is
assuming there was a legal strategy
because we know that Trump has the
president has tweeted this morning
approving of Rudy Giuliani's comments
last night and Rudy Giuliani was very
forceful when he talked to other news
outlets The Washington Post as well as
The Wall Street Journal this is the
strategy I Rudy Giuliani probably think
that the Southern District of New York
has a great deal of information from its
seizure of documents from Michael Cohen
right so I Rudy Giuliani advised the
president that we need to clean this up
because in my mind as a lawyer as I've
looked at all of this this was all legal
because it was your private funds that
paid back Michael Cohen over a period of
time from retainers so I'm going to go
on Sean Hannity friendly for him I'm
gonna clean it up for you so he says
disaster it was a disaster in my opinion
he says it's not campaign money who
determines whether it is campaign well
good question because what we have is
Michael Cohen never to forget out of the
goodness of his heart when in got
allegedly a home equity loan in order to
get this money have it transferred by a
bank to another bank in the name of a
dummy corporation in order to pay off
stormy Daniels and he didn't tell his
client the client Donald Trump knew
nothing about this well first of all
that's unethical on the part of a lawyer
in the New York Bar you can't pay
off a settlement out of retainer funds
and not have your client know you're
signing a contract in his name let alone
with an alias but then we have to look
back at the John Edwards case and look
is this an in-kind contribution to a
campaign by Michael Cohen whether or not
it is paid back later on in increments
by Donald Trump and then if it's alone
was there any interest paid no financial
disclosure forms ever showed the loan
there's so many bombshell yeah so many
questions thank you very much Ricky
claiming we're sorting it out